Hello Caroline, I'm Guy.
It's nice to finally meet you in person after talking on the phone.
It's a pleasure to meet you too.
I hope business is going well?
Yes, we have several new products in the pipeline, so it's pretty hectic.
Before we go any further,...
...I'd like you to meet Christina Pyle from our legal department.
She's going to be part of today's discussion...
...on revising the licensing agreement with your company.
Good to meet you, Ms. Pyle.
I've asked Christina to join us...
...so that she can approve any amendments to the agreement.
We want to make sure the changes do not conflict with our interests.
From our perspective, there are a few points of concern,...
...but I'm confident we can work out a new agreement that suits both parties.